all right so you've always known this
day would come still most parents aren't
sure how to cope with their children
going to college right so whether you're
happy maybe you're celebrating or you
know you're worried this is the first
time they're leaving the nest
conflicting feelings during moments like
this are very common mary jane bellezza
joins us live with how to cope with
empty nest syndrome mary jane good
morning
morning john and heather you know i went
to unlv so luckily my mom didn't have to
send me that far away but it is a pretty
difficult time for parents who are full
of different emotions maybe happy tears
maybe sad tears and you know it's all
pretty common like you said i spoke with
clinical psychologist renee solomon who
says it's important to stay in touch
with your child but give them space to
adjust to college life and their new
environment so try and schedule a time
to call or facetime when your child is
free to talk and away from distractions
take this time to focus on yourself or
catch up with loved ones or friends and
start a new routine
something that's just about you creating
new things in your routine especially
around the time of day when maybe you're
being connected with your child around
dinners maybe for the first week or two
try to go out or spend time with friends
dr salman says try to plan the next
visit with your child to give yourself
something to look forward to like a
weekend or the next holiday during
school break and she also says it's
important to give yourself some credit i
mean you've been spending this whole
time with your child planning their
departure so if they can do it you can
do it too reporting live at unlv mary
jane ballesa 8 news now